well it's time to celebrate them because
it's national rescue dog day
it's also a day to recognize how many
dogs are still
waiting at a shelter for their forever
home bianca holmen is live at the animal
foundation
and i know you're going to show us some
great little friends that are waiting to
be adopted bianca tell us more
yes sherry you know actually this
weekend i will admit i was a successful
dog mom this weekend dog sitting are one
of our producers pups
well his name is puppy but one of their
dogs and so it was just an amazing
experience and dogs just bring so much
joy to families
and to share more about national rescue
dog day
here joined by kelsey so tell us more
with the animal foundation
tell us more about how many dogs are
actually in
the facility right now and animals that
are available for adoption
so we have about 70 dogs waiting for
homes right now
and what perfect day to come in and
schedule that appointment
and find your new best friend yeah and i
know we have a telepathy it's a girl
right we were trying to figure out her
name
for a second this is the real star of
the show she's just a puppy she is
available for adoption she loves giving
kisses she is just
adorable so you can check out all her
information on our website if you're
interested give us a call this morning
yeah
and so also tell us you know why is it
so important to maybe come here to
rescue a dog rather than maybe go to a
breeder we have so many wonderful
animals just waiting
to go home with you plus if you rescue
you'll be saving a life
so who doesn't want that and is there i
know this is since it's warm outside
you all you're telling me you're going
to see an influx of actually animals
coming in
we're starting to see more animals come
into the shelter which happens every
year when the weather warms up
and of course fourth of july is right
around the corner so that will be our
busiest week
of the year yeah you know there's so
many benefits like you said saving a
life saving a puppy or a kitten i know
also kitten season so you do have some
cats available too
if dogs aren't your thing we have plenty
of kittens kitten season runs may
through september it also happens when
the weather warms up
so take a look at our website they are
so precious they're like one and a half
pounds all waiting for forever home
so cute so cute here he goes look she
was she behaved so she gets a nice treat
well also coming up we're going to talk
about the process of if you're
interested in adopting
a dog and someone to add to your hus a
pup to add to your family
and then also we're going to introduce
you to some puppies named after
a famous reality tv family that's a
little hint for you that's coming up
send it back to you guys in the studio
hey bianca how old is that puppy
uh puppy is uh how many weeks she's only
six weeks old that's why she's so tiny
but look she's pretty well behaved for a
six week old puppy
she is an angel bianca is she gonna get
big
sorry i'm asking for my personal is she
is she gonna get [ __ ] she's a wire
terrier we don't uh put any breed labels
on her dogs because we really don't know
without seeing her parents but if you
can see her paws they're pretty small so
she probably won't get
too big but there's just really no way
to know yeah and then she it does have
kind of a wired hair
feel to her okay adorable bianca thank
you so much
have fun out there oh my goodness
adorable dogs
so the reality show is the real house
pups of sunrise manor
yes i can't wait